Caption: good afternoon everybody thanks for
Caption: coming for the last session for today
Caption: um so we have Aiden Sophie here he is a
Caption: cloud native data engineer at kzn who's
Caption: on a mission to fight jargon one acronym
Caption: at a time
Caption: welcome Aiden
Caption: everyone hear me all right
Caption: cool
Caption: hello everyone and welcome to data lakes
Caption: and other bodies of water that killed
Caption: Big Data
Caption: before we begin I'd like to acknowledge
Caption: the traditional custodians of the land
Caption: the wardrock people of the nungan nation
Caption: I'd also like to say a big thank you to
Caption: all of the sponsors today as well as the
Caption: DDD uh volunteers have put a massive
Caption: effort in and it's made today flow very
Caption: smoothly so thank you
Caption: now
Caption: today I'm going to take you through the
Caption: death of big data and then dive into the
Caption: technology that has pushed it out of the
Caption: spotlight spoiler alert it's data leaks
Caption: then we're going to dive into what data
Caption: Lakes actually do
Caption: and following that I'll explain a few
Caption: other water analogies in the dart area
Caption: so my name is Aiden as we've just been
Caption: told and I'm a senior developer with kzn
Caption: kzn is a cloud consultancy that
Caption: specializes in serverless technology and
Caption: data engineering we have and continue to
Caption: build data Lakes for a range of our
Caption: clients
Caption: and let's get started
Caption: so
Caption: to kick off the story of how big data
Caption: went from buzzword number one to a thing
Caption: of the past I'm going to rewind to the
Caption: beginning of time and that was the
Caption: mid-1980s
Caption: in a simpler time
Caption: we had data
Caption: data was stored and data warehouses
Caption: we used SQL to extract value from that
Caption: data in the form of reporting
Caption: and that was it
Caption: very simple
Caption: they like it so
Caption: now as we move forward to roughly 2011
Caption: we get into the age of Big Data let's
Caption: define Big Data before we move forward
Caption: Big Data refers to data sets that are
Caption: too large or complex to deal with using
Caption: traditional methods traditional methods
Caption: largely being data warehouses
Caption: now what caused the rise of Big Data
Caption: lots of things but a major one with
Caption: social media companies realizing how
Caption: much money they can make from pushing us
Caption: personalized ads
Caption: other areas of Technology started to
Caption: pick up like iot
Caption: if you look at things like cars 20 years
Caption: ago they were purely Mechanical Devices
Caption: if you're lucky they had electric
Caption: windows but now we have companies like
Caption: Tesla or waymo where your cars are
Caption: streaming vast volumes of data up
Caption: to lose my sound
Caption: okay okay we're streaming vast volumes
Caption: of data up into the cloud from almost
Caption: every Appliance across the globe
Caption: to give some idea of scale in 2010
Caption: roughly 1.2 trillion gigabytes of data
Caption: was generated by the human race
Caption: in 2021 that number was 18 trillion
Caption: gigabytes we are on an x-band
Caption: exponential curve of data growth and the
Caption: scale of our data sets is more important
Caption: now than it ever has been
Caption: the problem
Caption: there was a few including structure
Caption: which we'll talk about later but the key
Caption: point I'm going to focus on here is the
Caption: pure volume traditional methods like
Caption: data warehouses just could not scale or
Caption: ingest data fast enough to keep up with
Caption: the demand and hence Big Data volumes of
Caption: information too large to be dealt with
Caption: using traditional methods
Caption: so what happened to this huge problem
Caption: that we saw on every News Channel and
Caption: every magazine cover
Caption: to give you an anticlimactic answer
Caption: the problem got solved
Caption: data Lakes provide a cheap and readily
Caption: available means of storing and ingesting
Caption: almost unlimited quantities of data
Caption: that's it
Caption: data Engineers can sleep at night and
Caption: everyone lived happily ever after
Caption: except it wasn't quite that simple
Caption: dialect solved a lot of the problems of
Caption: big data but in a classic Tech fashion
Caption: replace those problems with newer
Caption: challenges
Caption: but before we dig into that I'm hoping
Caption: at this stage you have one very simple
Caption: question bouncing around inside your
Caption: head what is a data Lake and how did it
Caption: solve these problems
Caption: well I'm glad you asked because someone
Caption: had to
Caption: start understanding data Lakes we're
Caption: going to need to look at data warehouses
Caption: that we talked about earlier
Caption: now data warehouses were the core of
Caption: business intelligence for the last 30
Caption: something years for those that are new a
Caption: data warehouse is a data management
Caption: system designed to enable business
Caption: intelligence activities that basically
Caption: means we have data and we want to get
Caption: value out of it
Caption: we can break this down a little bit by
Caption: looking at our key components we have a
Caption: data warehouse which has a database or a
Caption: variety of databases within it we have
Caption: etls that's the extraction
Caption: transformation and loading of data
Caption: between different sources
Caption: and then the system is set up in a way
Caption: that allows Integrations with external
Caption: Services whether it's an Erp system like
Caption: sap or Oracle or a CRM like Salesforce
Caption: through to analytics like power bi or
Caption: tableau
Caption: now the important thing to understand
Caption: about data warehouses is that they store
Caption: data in databases and databases only
Caption: accept structured data hence a data
Caption: warehouse can only store structured data
Caption: but what is structured data
Caption: now data can be structured or
Caption: unstructured and this is one of the keys
Caption: to understanding data lakes and the role
Caption: they play in superseding data warehouses
Caption: in the race to accommodate fast
Caption: quantities of data
Caption: let's start by looking at one of the
Caption: most common types of unstructured data a
Caption: CSV
Caption: now maybe the CSV came from a script
Caption: reading an API maybe it was an export
Caption: from some third-party system
Caption: as you can see we have data
Caption: but we know very little information
Caption: about this data
Caption: what are the data types
Caption: is that an integer or a decimal is it
Caption: signed or unsigned is this field allowed
Caption: to be null or should it have a default
Caption: value when it's empty is there a primary
Caption: key or is there a composite number of
Caption: columns that should uniquely identify a
Caption: row all of these questions are vitally
Caption: important for us to actually utilize our
Caption: data but they cannot be answered without
Caption: structure
Caption: this file for example could not be
Caption: loaded into a data warehouse unless we
Caption: knew what the structure was
Caption: so what does structure look like
Caption: I'm going to throw another very common
Caption: term around that everyone has heard but
Caption: a lot of people don't really understand
Caption: and that's metadata metadata is
Caption: information about data in our CSV
Caption: example metadata could be an information
Caption: file that provides answers to our
Caption: questions data types unique constraints
Caption: null handling
Caption: now there's another common type of
Caption: metadata involved with data lakes and
Caption: that's governance data when we have
Caption: hundreds or thousands of source systems
Caption: feeding into one big data platform it's
Caption: very important for us to know where that
Caption: data came from who's responsible for it
Caption: how often it's refreshed what the
Caption: quality is there's lots of questions
Caption: but for the sake of this speech we're
Caption: going to focus on the first type which
Caption: is the actual structure of our data we
Caption: can see you know this string has a
Caption: maximum length of 255 we can see that
Caption: this field is nullable this is the
Caption: structure to our data
Caption: so
Caption: what's very important to understand is
Caption: that when we have unstructured data and
Caption: the metadata that corresponds to it we
Caption: can combine those two things to produce
Caption: structured data okay
Caption: so
Caption: to solidify our metadata learnings
Caption: metadata is information about data this
Caption: information allows us to specifically
Caption: describe the format and structure of our
Caption: data and this allows us to treat the
Caption: data as structured which unlocks new
Caption: ways of analyzing storing and
Caption: classifying the information
Caption: now this is great but it feels like I'm
Caption: off on a tangent so why do we care about
Caption: structure
Caption: we care because of the definition of a
Caption: data Lake a centralized store for
Caption: structured and unstructured data at any
Caption: scale
Caption: the first big difference between a data
Caption: lake and a data warehouse is that data
Caption: Lakes accept any kind of data whereas
Caption: warehouses only accept structure a good
Caption: analogy is there's two toddlers and a
Caption: playground one of them is the picky kid
Caption: that only eats foods that are a certain
Caption: color and then you have the one in the
Caption: sandbox eating handfuls of sand
Caption: it's not bothering anyone but he doesn't
Caption: care he'll take anything in and that's
Caption: what a dog leg is
Caption: now in real life Business Systems the
Caption: majority of our inputs are usually
Caption: unstructured
Caption: exports from apis data dumps from
Caption: external systems and manually entered
Caption: information is normally unstructured but
Caption: as businesses want to make data-driven
Caption: decisions we need all of this
Caption: information to be stored in a structured
Caption: way
Caption: this is so we can accurately query it
Caption: for business Intelligence and Analysis
Caption: and that's what a data Lake does
Caption: it provides a single body for storing
Caption: structured and unstructured data as well
Caption: as defining automated processes for
Caption: adding structure to that data
Caption: let's dig into it a little bit more
Caption: everyone loves AWS architecture diagrams
Caption: so I threw one in
Caption: so
Caption: let's walk through it step by step
Caption: first on the left we have a range of
Caption: data sources some of these unstructured
Caption: some are structured
Caption: again that's the key difference between
Caption: a data warehouse and a data Lake all
Caption: inputs are accepted
Caption: next you'll notice there are two zones
Caption: an unstructured Zone and a structured
Caption: Zone
Caption: it's very important we have both of
Caption: these so that we can accept unstructured
Caption: or structured data in from outside
Caption: systems
Caption: it's also very important because as we
Caption: move data through a data Lake generally
Caption: we have a range of zones and as we move
Caption: through those zones our structure sorry
Caption: our data becomes more structured and has
Caption: a higher quality to it that's why we've
Caption: got the structured Zone to the right of
Caption: the unstructured zone
Caption: you can see between the two zones we
Caption: have a glue job this is AWS speak for an
Caption: ETL that's the extract transform and
Caption: load we talked about earlier
Caption: now this glue job takes unstructured
Caption: data and it applies metadata
Caption: to add structure to it and move it into
Caption: the structured Zone
Caption: it's worth noting that you can't just
Caption: throw a random CSV in and expect the
Caption: metadata to somehow be known for every
Caption: source that you ingest from you need to
Caption: have the metadata for that data set
Caption: once that data is sitting safe and
Caption: structured it can be brought into
Caption: into the structured Zone what I have
Caption: here is a data warehouse and an S3
Caption: bucket but what's important to
Caption: understand is that a data Lake does not
Caption: prescribe the tooling that we use okay
Caption: you can have a data Lake without a data
Caption: warehouse or you can have one with one
Caption: what matters is that you have a store
Caption: for that structured data
Caption: you can also see that we have a variety
Caption: of business
Caption: Integrations
Caption: like sagemaker that applies artificial
Caption: intelligence or predictive analysis over
Caption: the data power bi for visualization and
Caption: encoding
Caption: again these are not prescribed tools
Caption: these are commonly used ones but what
Caption: really matters in a data lake is that
Caption: you allow for the integration of
Caption: external services that provide this kind
Caption: of value
Caption: now data lakes also give us the
Caption: opportunity to tap into a buzzword that
Caption: Executives go crazy for and that's real
Caption: time
Caption: gives me shivers just saying it
Caption: what is real time basically it means
Caption: there's a very small turnaround between
Caption: an event occurring and that data being
Caption: presented to the end user that's it
Caption: any modern data Lake will provide
Caption: tooling that allows you to stream High
Caption: volumes of data in real time and the AWS
Caption: solution I'm showing you here is a
Caption: Kinesis stream
Caption: these streams go into a data store and
Caption: then we have an external tool like
Caption: rafana that reads it at very small time
Caption: intervals
Caption: again just one component inside the
Caption: ecosystem of a data Lake
Caption: now
Caption: this is why data Lake solve the big data
Caption: problem for everyday companies the cost
Caption: efficiency and scalability of the modern
Caption: Cloud allows us to store enormous
Caption: volumes of unstructured and structured
Caption: data without any real specialist input
Caption: we don't need big data phds to set up
Caption: Hadoop clusters and you rarely even need
Caption: database administrators because all of
Caption: your instances are running in managed
Caption: services that might be controversial
Caption: the problem of scaling is gone
Caption: so big data sets aren't scary anymore
Caption: I'm sure other big scary problems didn't
Caption: just take their place
Caption: except they did
Caption: common side effects of data Lake usage
Caption: include but are not limited to data
Caption: governance issues performance
Caption: performance complaints and massive scope
Caption: group
Caption: when you have thousands of data sets
Caption: coming from hundreds of sources being
Caption: transformed left right and Center it
Caption: gets very messy understanding who's
Caption: responsible for what data sets and what
Caption: they get used for if at all
Caption: next a 16 petabyte redshift cluster is
Caption: going to be slower to query than a 500
Caption: megabyte local Ms access file
Caption: that's the reality but end users don't
Caption: care about your excuses
Caption: and with scale come slow
Caption: another big one is that now that we have
Caption: all this amazing and readily accessible
Caption: data we need to do more with it than
Caption: just run reports data Lakes represent a
Caption: big step forward in enabling machine
Caption: learning as well as predictive analysis
Caption: and automated decision making
Caption: because solving a problem isn't enough
Caption: once we can do something we have to
Caption: figure how to get the most value out of
Caption: it
Caption: and suddenly our problem of there's too
Caption: much data to store becomes a problem of
Caption: how do we get the most out of all this
Caption: data that we have
Caption: anyway this slide is not here for
Caption: Solutions only pessimism and now that we
Caption: understand what a data lake is and how
Caption: it killed big data we can move on to the
Caption: next item
Caption: which is other bodies of water
Caption: now it's worth noting while I'm here
Caption: that this speech to some extent
Caption: is an opinion piece there is no uh
Caption: standard body that defines exactly what
Caption: a data lake or a data Pond or a data
Caption: bottle is
Caption: they're just kind of terms that people
Caption: have come up with and every company uses
Caption: them in a slightly different way
Caption: but
Caption: for some reason a lot of Next Generation
Caption: data infrastructure follows water naming
Caption: so let's start with the biggest and the
Caption: most difficult to understand the data
Caption: swap
Caption: simply pull it a data swamp is a bad
Caption: data Lake
Caption: data swamps come around when we have
Caption: poor data quality or poor data
Caption: governance they're bad don't do them any
Caption: questions no good
Caption: okay next we're moving down the scale a
Caption: data puddle is a single purpose data
Caption: Lake used by a specialist team for a
Caption: very specific reason
Caption: it is often used as companies migrate
Caption: into the cloud and want to dip their
Caption: toes and test things out for one
Caption: specific use case before they try to
Caption: scale up and move their whole business
Caption: over
Caption: you can see this in my extravagant
Caption: diagram where a collection of happy
Caption: synergistic teams make use of a data
Caption: Lake whereas one sad lonely solitary
Caption: team makes use of their sad lonely data
Caption: bottle
Caption: we don't see these too wild on the often
Caption: and if I'm honest I'd never heard of
Caption: this term before I started researching
Caption: for the speech but these are generally
Caption: used as a proof of concept or by a road
Caption: team that is sick of their company's
Caption: data architecture
Caption: that said
Caption: wow that really resonated all right that
Caption: said they provide an important role in
Caption: our next body of water
Caption: the data pond
Caption: this can be described as a collection of
Caption: small isolated Data Systems and you
Caption: might have a a dozen different teams who
Caption: each have their own data puddle on
Caption: shared infrastructure the key difference
Caption: here between a data pond and a data lake
Caption: is minimal shared governance or data the
Caption: accounting team uses their accounting
Caption: data that they ingested the engineering
Caption: team uses their engineering data that
Caption: they ingested but there's not a lot of
Caption: crossover
Caption: it's not one huge big lake of shared
Caption: data that everyone Taps into for their
Caption: own purposes
Caption: this again is often seen as a stepping
Caption: stone to data Lakes but for smaller
Caption: companies it may be suitable on its own
Caption: so in summary who killed Big Data
Caption: it was the data Lake in the cloud with
Caption: the scalability
Caption: in a more General sense Cloud technology
Caption: has provided everyday businesses with
Caption: the ability to scale their data
Caption: infrastructure much more easily than
Caption: before and as a result the traditional
Caption: methods that couldn't handle big data
Caption: have become a thing of the past
Caption: we've learned that the data Lakes are
Caption: just big fancy ways of storing any kind
Caption: of data that you want and data ponds and
Caption: data puddles are scaled down less
Caption: collaborative versions of data Lakes
Caption: are there any questions
Caption: sure sorry I'm putting on the spot there
Caption: oh
Caption: is the unstructured data a key part of
Caption: being a data Lake absolutely yeah
Caption: um if you it's not just the size and
Caption: scale available and structured
Caption: structured data so the issue with the
Caption: data warehouse the preceded Lakes was
Caption: that a database needs structure in order
Caption: to ingest data so if you want to accept
Caption: data sources from literally anywhere and
Caption: not be picky you need to accept
Caption: unstructured data because a lot of
Caption: sources will give us unstructured data
Caption: I was just gonna ask uh have you heard
Caption: of the so-called lake house and do you
Caption: have an opinion yes
Caption: um
Caption: so lake house is commonly sold through
Caption: databricks as one of their products
Caption: um
Caption: my understanding of it is it's very good
Caption: for an organization that wants a data
Caption: Lake but doesn't have a lot of data
Caption: engineering capability themselves so
Caption: it's if you're laughing you worked for
Caption: databricks or something
Caption: it's a way of tying in machine learning
Caption: and artificial intelligence and data
Caption: governance all into a data Lake it's a
Caption: bit of an expansion of a data Lake and
Caption: it's a bit of a managed product
Caption: cool
Caption: are there any other end I saw you walk
Caption: to the back just so I could ask that
Caption: question and what are your thoughts on
Caption: data mesh
Caption: new term to me
Caption: yep I'll be honest
Caption: what are your thoughts
Caption: I think it's a way of solving some of
Caption: the the problems that are going to come
Caption: okay with
Caption: data lakes and data warehouses and
Caption: rebuilding that monolith of data and but
Caption: I was just wondering I won't go into
Caption: detail your presentation yeah
Caption: I can understand why uh the data lake is
Caption: very appealing to company and I'm
Caption: curious about how in the wild people
Caption: actually make use of it I mean like in
Caption: your diagram there's there's the AI
Caption: bolt-on and there's a dashboard but what
Caption: do people tend to actually do with their
Caption: data Lakes
Caption: a lot of reporting
Caption: um
Caption: generally from what I found companies
Caption: will have uh segregated data silos and
Caption: part of their technical Revolution
Caption: whatever is to move to a data Lake and
Caption: start to bring all of that data into one
Caption: place I think that has some very real
Caption: benefits in that previously you know
Caption: opposite or different teams would have a
Caption: lot of trouble accessing the data of
Caption: other teams and there's a complete
Caption: nightmare of managing you know 100
Caption: different database clusters and everyone
Caption: having their own way there's very little
Caption: governance in those so what I see
Caption: happening is generally just
Caption: consolidating all of that into one
Caption: platform that everyone can use it does
Caption: generate a lot of work for them because
Caption: suddenly data governance becomes a must
Caption: instead of a could but largely what I've
Caption: see it used for is dashboards and
Caption: Reporting makes sense thanks cool
Caption: think we maybe have time for one more
Caption: quick question yeah
Caption: um what about security so if you have
Caption: everyone accessing this data Lake how do
Caption: you keep secure data from people who
Caption: shouldn't see it sure
Caption: um
Caption: personally we work within AWS so my ads
Caption: will be a bit constrained there but
Caption: um as with any other system you have to
Caption: secure access in some way there's good
Caption: ways and bad ways of doing that when it
Caption: comes to things like databases
Caption: themselves you can generate you know you
Caption: have to generate credentials for people
Caption: to log in and use and however you manage
Caption: that is your thing for the unstructured
Caption: stores or S3 buckets and things like
Caption: that we always recommend that SSO is
Caption: used to authenticate and that way you
Caption: can control that only people in your you
Caption: know active directory domain are able to
Caption: access that data but it is a very broad
Caption: question in that every company is going
Caption: to handle that a slightly different way
Caption: oh awesome thank you so much Aiden cool
Caption: um thank you yes